as if marvel couldn't get any cooler
check this out we teamed up with wounded
warrior project for their new make me a
hero campaign we have a sneak peek at
their new video i am a big fan of the
marvel movies my favorite characters are
iron man of course thor because let's
face it it's thor and i like black widow
in this four-part digital series marvel
artists honor veterans and their
caretakers by transforming these
real-life heroes into cool comic book
characters that includes janice whose
son morgan was on active duty when he
collapsed after suffering a seizure and
cardiac arrest i'm a caregiver
for my son morgan he really hates having
a brain injury his brain injury affected
all of us our whole family it changed
the dynamics and i ended up resigning
from a job i loved in order to be able
to help him
wounded warrior project supports
veterans and their families providing
free programs and life-changing services
to those in need they also support the
caregivers by giving us retreats so we
can have some self-care for ourselves to
meet other family members who are going
through the exact same thing that we are
oh wow
look at her
check out janice's big reveal tomorrow
on marvel.com and find out how wounded
warrior project helps veterans by
visiting
woundedwarriorproject.org thanks marvel
and wounded warrior project for making
me a hero
[Music]
you